hi I'm Sydney Park I'm Eli brown I'm
Sophia Carson I'm Sasha Pieterse F I'm
Janel Parrish and we're here at BuzzFeed
to play a little game called who's who
[Music]
she's always perfect
Jerry really looks perfect she takes the
most perfect pictures I think we're all
in a different way I think we're all
just that overwhelmed so I kind of went
like this like cute
me I just maybe this you tell jokes oh
yeah I was gonna say these two oh you
can cut it I'll show you guys in and
tell a story and then I will feel like
I'm skating I'll let them listen for
like one or two minutes this earlier
said because it's such an intricate
story it's like I really I really
because deez nutz between the two is
between the two brothers over here and
then they make everybody else laughs
yeah once it starts it's like over heads
all over your eyes together and it's
really somebody that you laugh at that
it's like when you go to say the line
again you remember that everybody
laughed and then you start laughing and
then I started to snore it in this book
together eventually
it's our 16 we're usually pretty loopy
yeah Sydney and I do this thing where we
wait well we look away from each other
because we can't look at each other
oh yeah I know I know let's go yeah
[Music]
I'll appointed me to yeah I may have
weird little songs when I'm tired at a
theme park she makes up jingles for
every ride I do but then you'll burst
into song I was facing oh it'll get you
stuck in our head like a share the one
that you created undeserving Lassie
oh that one but there's nothing you to
do to do to do to do to do to save space
mountains the way to go Space Mountain
doot doot doot see I just wake up little
jingles when I'm tired or I'm delirious
and I just start singing it and we all
learned in that
[Music]
not caught will she's a baker like
forever yeah I'm the designated selfie
whatever we have social media we're like
here you can see my daddy arms too I'm
really terrible is it me I'm just a bad
liar well both of us we have we've kept
secrets for 10 years that's true I'm
gonna be so no keep it a secret and
lying are two totally different things
that is missing sugars higher value from
somebody's business on luck is not a lie
[Music]
I trust all of you what taste you all I
think we're pretty good that's you who
you like a look at it like this and
Saturday I was working with and my
sister was excipients very bone out the
winter which is crazy how a planet with
anything is on their side email I heard
that we are starting to get indents in
our fingers from holding our phone but
Eli has a flip phone so they want to see
the body the body your body beautiful we
flip it flip it mom
I think I've done pretty good so far so
far he goes into an interview and he
says something maybe if it's not if he's
not supposed to he's I'm sure he goes
Amanda is that okay yes
[Music]
we're all pretty on it I was I was late
no one morning I set my alarm for 4:20
p.m. instead of 4:20 a.m. on accident
how late were you I don't want to say
but but I got it I got I got a call and
it was like it was so early I thought
they were just gonna tell me like we
don't need you today I was like so out I
was like they're gonna they don't need
me today I picked up he's like where are
you what you're supposed to be here 30
minutes ago I showed up to work on the
opposite like I need to be at work at
5:00 a.m. freaking out and it was
actually 5 p.m. hey guys thank you so
much for watching we had so much fun and
don't forget to watch Pretty Little
Liars perfectionist on freeform on
Wednesdays at 8:00
[Music]